collègues l'ordre du jour appelle la
question orale numéro 533 de madame
catherine procast ya un monsieur le
ministre chargé des transports de la mer
et de la pêche
vous avez la parole merci madame la
présidente
bonjour madame la ministre merci de
répondre sur une question qui est quand
même assez éloigné de vos activités du
ministère et même de la région d'où vous
venez
elle concerne les dysfonctionnements du
site internet du trafic de
l'ile-de-france qui s'appelle citadine
la direction des routes d'ile-de-france
qui s'appelle la dirif permet aux
usagers du réseau routier
d'ile-de-france d'anticiper leurs
déplacements en choisissant un
itinéraire le plus adapté grâce à un
site internet citadine qui à l'époque
quand il a été mis en place fut une
révolution
ils permettent normalement une
information en temps réel sur les
conditions de circulation et
d'exploitation du réseau routier
francilien
j'aurais dû dire qu'il permettait aux
usagers du réseau routier d'île de
france puisque maintenant ce n'est plus
le cas à l'origine ce site a été si
performant qu'il a été copiée et mis en
place dans d'autres grandes villes qui
elle maintenant ont un système qui
fonctionne ce qui n'est plus le cas en
ile-de-france le plan interactif du
réseau présente depuis de nombreuses
années et en permanence des zones grises
et qui correspondent à des zones qui ne
sont pas remplacés renseigné plutôt
excusez moi ces zones sont
particulièrement nombreuses
souvent stratégique et remettent en
cause l'intérêt du système
ce matin j'ai regardé la carte avant de
reposer cette question je ne sais pas je
pense que vous ne la voyez pas mais elle
présente de nombreuses zones grises et
en particulier dans des points
stratégiques qui vont jusqu'à
l'autoroute
l'autoroute a1 et l'autoroute a3 vert
vers charles-de-gaulle l'aéroport ce qui
est quand même particulièrement ennuyeux
et aussi sur la francilienne en route
très empruntée voie très empruntée sur
la francilienne sur le côté est aussi
cette défaillance résulte de problèmes
techniques ou d'actes de vandalisme
comme le vol des câbles mais je ne
comprends pas pourquoi des systèmes de
navigation gratuit comme google maps ou
d'autres systèmes sont eux capables de
donner des informations plutôt fiable
même expérience ce matin sur google maps
tout est bien indiquée avec le trafic et
on sait comment ça roule et où sont les
bouchons ce qui n'est plus le cas sur
citadine
il me semble que l'île de france mérite
un système qui la couvre dans son
intégralité et j'aimerais bien que notre
région redevienne pilote en ce domaine
sans compter madame la ministre que
l'est parisien
nous nous plaignons toujours des
conditions de circulation et
d'exploitation et des entreprises l'est
parisien est particulièrement mal
couverts alors pouvez vous m'indiquer
madame la ministre étant le réseau sera
de nouveau opérationnel enfin lorsque
j'avais posé la question
j'avais demandé si à l'image de la ratp
des réseaux sociaux allaient enfin
pouvoir faire appel et mettre sur le
réseau citadine
j'ai constaté très récemment puisque
c'est moins de deux semaines que
citadine est dorénavant sur twitter sans
aucune information
et avec un nombre d'abonnés
impressionnant puisqu'il est moins 200
personnes c'est-à-dire qu'aucune
information n'a été fait en tout cas je
me réjouis effectivement qu'il soit
enfin sur citadine geste citadines sont
enfin sur twitter et j'espère que c'est
ma question qui a permis de susciter
cette vocation
merci chers collègues vous avez la
parole même le ministre pour répondre à
notre collègue
merci madame la sénatrice catherine
procaccia comme on dirait chez moi
je vous avez bien voulu effectivement
appelé l'attention de frédéric cuvillier
qui est ministre des transports et de la
mer et de la pêche sur les
dysfonctionnements du site internet
citadine qui date de 1996 et vise à
informer les usagers en temps réel de
l'état du trafic routier francilien
il me concerne aussi donc ne vous
inquiétez pas faire d'abord fonctionner
un tel système est un défi quotidien
vous le savez car pour recueillir ces
informations il faut la collaboration
étroite de différents textes exploitants
de réseau routier les sociétés
concessionnaires la ville de paris les
forces de police du centre régional
d'information et de coordination
routière d'ile-de-france donc une
véritable coordination pour arriver à
faire fonctionner le réseau
le système est composé de 2500 points de
comptage plus de 6000 boucles de
comptage dans les chaussées et plus de
30000 équipements électroniques
environ 3000 km de câbles certaines
zones de dispose d'ailleurs pas encore
de matériel de recueil de données
la complexité est en outre accru par le
fait que la plupart de ces équipements
sont exposés à un milieu extrêmement
agressif variations de température
présence d'eau en particulier au bord
des routes
ce qui génère un vieillissement accéléré
du réseau les pannes générés sont
traitées en temps réel
autant que le permet la complexité
d'intervenir sur un réseau routier à un
très haut niveau de trafic les câbles
d'alimentation électrique et de
transmission des données en cuivre vous
le précise y est tout à leur font
l'objet de vols et de dégradations de
plus en plus fréquente de plus en plus
régulières le préjudice est telle qu'il
n'est plus possible de réparer
rapidement et à l'identique d'ailleurs
le coût s'élève à des centaines de
milliers d'euros des opérations de
réparations sont en cours quand c'est
techniquement possible le plus vite
possible sécurisation des câbles d'abord
et des installations en reprenant
profondément le système au fur à mesure
que nous réparons de nouveaux
équipements sont donc en cours de mise
en oeuvre sur les autoroutes du nord s
qui devrait être installé d'ailleurs à
l'été prochain à l'été 2014 pour ces
raisons et ce sont ces raisons qui
expliquent ce que vous appeliez ce qui
s'appelle les zones grises
je le découvre en ce qui me concerne sur
le site citadine
mais avec les évolutions scientifiques
et techniques les équipements de bord de
route ne sont plus aujourd'hui les
seules sources d'information pour
estimer l'état du trafic
mais je tiens à dire que la présence
d'opérateurs pour la surveillance
continue du réseau routier font
réellement de citadine une source fiable
d'information pour les usagers alors
pour améliorer et c'est nécessaire pour
améliorer la diffusion des projets sont
en cours d'étude
la dernière version du site internet
date d'octobre 2012 et celle du site
mobile d'avril 2013
les échanges se poursuivent avec les
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroute
avec les conseils généraux avec la ville
de paris en ce moment l'est même pour
élargir la diffusion des informations
ainsi que pour élargir le périmètre des
routes concernées et nous allons aller
plus loin parce que grâce peut-être à
vous nous avons mis en place
l'utilisation du tweet mais nous allons
aller plus loin pour effectivement
rendre meilleur l'utilisation de twitter
voilà madame la sénatrice il madame la
ministre madame trop cassia
souhaitez-vous réagir aux propos de
madame la ministre
oui merci vous me parlez madame la
ministre de la fiabilité la toujours ce
matin j'ai regardé fiabilité pour aller
dans une commune de l'est de paris à
l'aéroport de roissy
citadine dit lui même fiabilité 34% 22
minutes
théoriquement pour y aller fiabilité 34
% peut-on appeler de fiabilité quand on
met 34% et sur google maps
au lieu de mettre les 22 minutes on en
mai 42 et ça me paraît beaucoup plus
fiable donc il ya quand même d'autres
systèmes
le ministre vous demande d'évoquer
l'extension du système citadine et des
cas vaudrait peut-être mieux déjà que
les partis fonctionnent parce que les
partis que je vous citais à l'est de
paris ça fait deux ans trois ans qu'à
chaque fois on me répond vol de câbles
donc le cam n'est peut-être pas la
solution
maintenant il ya des solutions qui sont
plus modernes et en particulier le
satellite
je présume je ne sais pas comment
fonctionne google mais c'est à travers
les satellites
pourquoi citadine en attendant de
trouver un autre système ne reprend que
ne reprend pas les informations de
google ou d'un autre par le biais des
câbles pour pouvoir a indiqué sur ces
zones grises et quel est le temps et
refaire des calculs au lieu de rêve de
ne pas vouloir ré inventer autre chose
je crois que ça va nous coûter très très
cher et les câbles depuis le temps
qu'ils ont été volés
je peux vous assurer qu'ils auraient eu
le temps d'être remplacé trois fois même
s'ils coûtent très cher donc la réponse
est très cher mais est-ce que la dirif
ne pourrait pas inventer autre chose
et effectivement au lieu de reproduire
les erreurs du passé
essayez de mettre en place un système un
petit peu plus efficace c'est pour le
bien non pas simplement de tous ceux de
la région parisienne des entreprises qui
l'utilisent
mais de tous les usagers qui du nord et
de l'est de la france vont aller dans le
sud et passe par la francilienne et
passe par le périphérique plutôt que de
savoir comment ça roule dans certaines
petites rues de paris il vaudrait mieux
que sur les grands axes
on est des informations en tout cas
merci madame la ministre d'avoir eu la
gentillesse de me répondre mais si chers
collègues lors du jour appelle la
question rahal numéro 564 de robert
tropéano
ah mais